The visitor count for a small doctor's office today would
be relatively small. So, we can probably get away with
an int, and we would write that as 123. The
number of gallons used could be pretty much anything. We
don't know what it's being used for, so it could
be two or 2 million. It probably doesn't have to
be an integer. You could have 2.5 gallons of water.
So, this should be a double, and we could write it
as 123 point or 1.23E2. Either one of these would
work for initializing this variable. PageViews, or the number of pages
of a website viewed by users this quarter, could be a
very large number. Think about how many YouTube videos get watched.
But it has to be an integer number because it's a
count. So I would use a long. And when you initialize
a long, you would use something like 123L. Half-life, a measure
of how long it takes a signal from a radioactive oxygen
isotope to decrease by half is another double. There's nothing to guarantee
that this would be another integer value. We could initialize this again
using 123 point or 1.23E2. And for this case, and also the
gallons case, we could have just written 123. That would work as well.